i guess i should be flattered
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy that's the reason why it's happening
that i'm a decent man or whatever's
phrased that you know that's why they're
coming because no biden's a good guy
truth of the matter is nothing has
changed
as many people came
that was president joe biden last week
telling america that the situation at
the border has not changed but
the numbers tell a completely different
story we have those numbers here
this chart shows the spike from just one
year ago
and as you can see it is spiking senator
ted cruz told us on this program last
week
he believes this is a direct consequence
of
three critical decisions that joe biden
made during his first week as president
watch
number one he immediately halted
construction of the border wall and we
saw sections of the border wall where
literally
they're half done and there's rusted
rebar everywhere they just left it they
just left it with holes in it
and of course the illegal traffic is
streaming through those holes
number two joe biden reinstated
the the failed catch and release policy
which in other words when someone is
caught they end up being given a court
date sometime in the future released and
everyone knows
a very small percentage of them ever
show up again
and number three and this was probably
the most inexplicable
biden ended the remain in mexico
agreement
and generally now is former acting dhs
secretary chad wolf he was instrumental
in implementing president trump's border
policies and he is with us now secretary
it's always a pleasure to see you
thanks for being here good morning to
you do you agree with what you just
heard from ted cruz as the three most
important things
that biden did to overturn trump
policies and in fact
in doing so caused this surge at the
border
well the senator's certainly right those
three measures
certainly impacted the surge that we see
now and i would add on to that
the fact that the administration is not
enforcing a title 42 cdc public health
order on miners is
contributing directly to the surge that
we see in minors today
over five six thousand in cbp custody
we will see historic numbers of miners
coming into the country
over the next several months because of
the biden administration's specific
measure not to employ that public health
order for minors remember this
maria they're using this public health
authority to turn around single adults
they're even using it to turn around
some families who have minors
they're even turning around minors back
to mexico but they will not turn around
minors back to the northern triangle
put them on planes and reunite them with
the families which is what we did
during the trump administration this is
having a very significant effect
on the surge that we see with minors and
certainly the remaining mexico program
or mpp
is certainly contributing to the surge
that we see with family units and the
catch and release that the senator
talked about
yeah i mean i it's it's so important to
go through this
and and you know we know that joe biden
carved out uh an exception for families
that have minors
families with a six-year-old or younger
and like
you know just like that we suddenly see
families with six-year-olds or younger
but they're renting these kids right
it's not even their kids
they just are trying to have the cookie
cutter that joe biden said he'll let in
what we know is that the cartels and the
smugglers and the traffickers are very
sophisticated and they listen to
public pronouncements and they know our
policies and procedures so when the bite
administration
starts to carve out different
populations and groups of individuals
those are exactly as you indicated those
are the groups of individuals we start
seeing at the border because
that's who they go and recruit but at
the end of the day the administration
right now
is not uh enforcing or not there is no
immigration
consequence to illegal behavior they're
simply treating this as a capacity issue
so they're building more facilities
they're trying to process more
individuals through
and they're not holding individuals
accountable for that illegal behavior
and that's what you have to do at the
end of the day
to stop the crisis and the surge that we
see on the border
so there's going to be a number of
policies that are going to need to be
changed and enforced
if we want to see an end to this so what
are the
border agents telling you on the ground
one of my sources
on the border told me that there will be
5 000
agents retiring and that the biden
administration is not going to replace
them
it seems like our officials on the
ground
those people on the front lines border
customs
patrol are dealing with this with their
hands tied
behind their backs also
customs and border patrol chief hastings
uh tweeted this
this that this year alone rio grande
valley sector agents found more than 860
criminal aliens
including 92 sex offenders 64 members of
violent gangs so they're dealing with
this
on the ground representative henry henry
cuellar from texas said
thousands are being released into texas
on the honor system
without court information or notices to
appear
so you've got some some really tough
you know dealings that our border agents
have to face off
meanwhile you've got 5 000 of them about
to retire
yeah it's absolutely uh frustrating for
border patrol agents today and i've
talked to
to several of them those in the rio
grande valley the rgv which is sort of
ground zero for where a lot of this
surge is occurring
almost half half of them are no longer
on the border doing that national
security mission they're
they're back at border patrol stations
carrying and feeding for these thousands
of individuals
in their facilities that's not what they
signed up for that's not their training
their training is to enforce the law
making sure that drugs contraband and
other illegal
migrants are not coming into the country
over half of them
in rgv are not doing that today so i
think that's why you see perhaps
an increase in the number of criminals
and others because we know the cartels
will take advantage of that
but at the end of the day i think
there's also our border patrol agents
listened to tv
listen to television and some of the
announcements and pronouncements that
are coming from
dhs leadership as well as the white
house and so when they hear
that leadership saying the border is
closed the border is secure they know
that's a lie
they know that's a lie and i believe
there's a loss of confidence
in both departmental leadership as well
as uh in the white house
with your line agents at the border
patrol
yeah and that has massive unintended
consequences real quick who do you think
is in jar
in charge joe biden said kamala harris
is in charge of the border she said no
no
no i'm not taking that on i'm just doing
diplomacy
well it's very confusing you have a dhs
secretary you have a southern border
coordinator out of the white house you
have a vice president
you have an envoy envoy sorry envoy from
the state department
it's all very confusing and what this
tells you
is that there's a lot of high-level
individuals from the administration
focused on this
because of the crisis because of the
historic nature of what we're seeing at
the border
unbelievable we'll see if they make a
change and take a maya culpa
and reinstitute president trump's and
your
guidelines and policies which fix the
situation for time
chad wolf it's great to have you this
weekend thanks so much